four clubs of course just aren't just
businesses
they define communities across the
country
so along with almost every member of
this house i suspect
i was appalled by the announcement made
late last night
that a handful of clubs are proposing to
form their own
breakaway european league
these six clubs announce this decision
without any consultation with football
authorities or with government
worst of all they did it without any
dialogue whatsoever
with their own fans it was
a tone-deaf proposal but the owners of
those clubs won't have been able to
ignore the near universal
raw of outrage from all parts of the
football community over the past
24 hours this move indeed goes against
the very spirit
of the game this is a sport where a team
like leicester city can ascend from
league one
to the premier league title in under a
decade earning the right to go
toe-to-toe against european heavyweights
in the champions league
instead a small handful of owners
want to create a closed shop of elite
clubs at the top of the game
a league based on wealth and brand
recognition
rather than upon merit we will not
stand by and watch football be cravingly
stripped of the things that make
millions across the country love it
as a conservative i believe passionately
in defending our nation's institutions
and our rich heritage they are central
to our identity
and help build a sense of solidarity
between people from every generation
and every background and just as the
government wouldn't hesitate to act when
other treasured areas of our national
life are under threat
nor will we hesitate to protect one of
our greatest national
institutions football
this is of course for football
authorities to handle first
and today i have met with the premier
league the football association
and the president of uefa whilst the
sports minister has had another of a
series of meetings with the footballers
supporters association
the football authorities have robust
rules in place to deal with this
and i know from my conversations with
them today that they are rightly
considering a wide range of sanctions
and measures
to stop this move in its tracks my
message to them was clear
they have our full backing
but madam deputy speaker be
in no doubt if they can't act
we will we will put everything on the
table to prevent this from happening
we are examining every option from
governance reform
to competition law and mechanisms that
allow football to take place
put simply we will be reviewing
everything the government does
to support these clubs to play i've
discussed these options with the prime
minister this morning
and we are working at pace across
government and with football authorities
i want to reassure this house of a very
robust
response we will do whatever it
takes to protect our national game
but it's clearer than ever that we need
a proper examination of the long-term
future of football
to many fans in this country the game is
now almost unrecognizable from a few
decades ago
season after season year after year
football fans demonstrate unwavering
loyalty and passion by sticking by their
clubs
but their loyalty is being abused by a
small number of
individuals who wield an incredible
amount of power and influence
these if the the past year has taught us
anything
it's that football is nothing without
its fans
and these owners should remember that
they are only temporary custodians of
their clubs
and they forget fans at their peril
that's why over the past few months i've
been meeting with fans and
representative organizations
to develop our proposals for a fan-led
review
i'd always been clear that i didn't want
to launch this until football had
returned to normal
following the pandemic sadly these clubs
have made it clear
that i have no choice they have decided
to put money before fans so today
i have been left with no choice but to
formally trigger the launch of our
fan-led review of
football the review will be chaired by
the honourable member for chatham and
aylesford
and will be a root and branch
examination of football in this country
it will cover the financial
sustainability of the men's and women's
game
governance and regulation and the merits
of an independent
regulator crucially in the light of this
weekend's proposal
it will also consider how fans can have
an even greater say
in the oversight of the game and the
models which might
best achieve that we are the people's
government
we are unequivocally on the side of fans
and their voices have to be heard when
it comes to the future of our national
game
it starts with fans and it ends with
fans
but in the meantime we have thrown our
full weight behind the football
authorities
and stand ready to do whatever is
necessary to represent fans and protect
their interests
and i commend this statement to the
house